some of what's been said you're kinda
racist I'm cool with it that's a little
bit racist latest installment of real
conversations changed my mind the full
unedited interview will be coming up
soon I know that's why you tune in these
these are our segments where we have
full unedited uncut interviews usually
involving a topic that's somewhat
controversial just to prove that you can
have conversations with people and
sometimes Minds can be changed and
sometimes you can part ways and
sometimes there's nothing productive
happens sometimes nothing productive
happens and today's a little bit
different because this comes from when
we were at TCU we were doing the mail
privileges of myth which turned into a
meme changed my mind
and then I sat down with a couple of
people they were very beautiful and have
a conversation that day it was one of
our less productive changed my mind days
they wanted to go to the the white
privilege thank you so well sure you
interpreted the sign is saying white
male privilege yes white male privilege
either that was a thing and we'll show
you that in a bit and that's what
actually spawned a conversation between
a black gentleman and an Asian gentleman
they prefer Orientals they do not agree
with the previous black girl who was
talking about white male privilege and
how I was not entitled to an opinion so
we'll get she was trying to speak on
behalf of all all black men yeah exactly
in this black guy said like I don't
agree with that and so he came up and he
spoke and he sat down they talked about
cultural differences with us you'll see
this this Asian gentleman there and it
was it was really fun this is not really
an argument and actually I think the
black guy was a fan so full disclosure
so that it's not that what you're used
to but I just thought it was something
really cool was an organic conversation
that warranted a watch and I will say
this with it with the real conversations
that changed my mind segments we've been
very happy overall with what will we say
70% positive maybe Larry more than that
it's pretty rare I mean I think I think
even if you have to be a pretty hateful
little booger to just find this to be
like an evil well yeah I mean there were
a couple of those there's like the guy
the white male pros VI frustrating SMU
they tried to run us out in a rail which
is why we're going back to perform
on March 22nd and the feminist said it
was male priviledge II yes in the first
place but yes I'm you they got pretty
mad so that was one where there are a
few like they were they were pretty
upset and that's why we're going back in
the 22nd so book now but I'd say you
know I'd say I would say 70% trying to
be Jenner 70% been positive and 30% have
been somewhat hostile and I will tell
you this though any success that we've
had with this segment when we first
started doing it we said you know if
there's any success with this at all if
we're able to actually keep it civil and
actually have a conversation we want to
have with people the kind of
conversation that we've always had off
air with new people yep sometimes new
hires or sometimes when when people show
up to live shows we'll sit and I'll talk
to you for a long time sometimes even
just nuba right or at an uber ride for
exactly around so if there were if there
were a me level of success with this
series we would have been happy let
alone to see how much it's been embraced
by people out there because that doesn't
really happen in the age of the
clickbait title and everyone wanting to
talk about controversy and anti fun and
obviously that's that's that's reality
you have to deal in reality but you can
also have these kinds of conversations
that are very productive there there are
two sides of that coin and you don't
really hear this other side so we're
pretty happy I would say overall I mean
I would consider something that would
probably really would consider most
proud of here on this let's proud of it
and we kind of fell into it yeah there
wasn't a plan thing it was like let's
just try this and let's see and we
didn't expect much to come of it yeah to
the porter we get a lot of requests
probably more for this than anything
else yeah we have entire campus shows
and tour shows that people want right
just for change my mind coming to mind
right which is very different on the
live show a different at SMU in the 22nd
and then Illinois in March but we will
go to different campuses and do that do
to change my mind segments going forward
so first off let's show you the this was
supposed to be male privilege is a myth
and this lady decided to take a
different direction
[Music]
[Music]
what are your names I'm Hannah Hannah
Marilyn Hannah and Marilyn Jared how do
you okay Hannah and Marilyn so it's sort
of become this neologism this idea of
male privilege and I know we talk about
it a lot on campus and I've had some
conversations with people on campus
today I don't agree with the premise but
I'm open to having my mind changed well
male privilege is definitely a real
thing okay
our country country was built by white
males and it was built for white males
that's why women and any minority don't
have an equal chance of being in
politics that's why most of our
politicians are white males instead of
representative of the actual politic of
the actual population that's why
gerrymandering exists that's why
redlining is this white privilege and
white male privilege and male privilege
is real things okay so I want to make
sure I have this clear do you agree with
what yeah absolutely
okay sorry I'm trying to try and balance
this with the both you hope hope you
forgive me if I'm not perfect so you
believe that this country was founded by
white males exclusively I don't believe
it was I no innovation okay you know it
so what would use to substantiate that a
lot of white males obviously came here
because you know Western Western
civilization people came from Europe lot
of white males I thought it was founded
exclusively for white males that's what
you said yeah how did Amin ated Society
but that doesn't imply that that doesn't
necessarily equate to design the the
Constitution originally didn't mention
women
black people or anything or minorities
or anything and only mentioned white men
it didn't specifically say white but it
said man they didn't give any minorities
the right to anything we had to fight
for that right who's we
the minorities women had to people of
color had to everyone had to except for
white males I'm sorry I'm confused so
you're saying that the Constitution
first off mentioned only white men I
would say it denied man it said men give
mankind men turn you know again this is
just sort of a colloquialism men the
rights were extended to women you're
here aware right they weren't extended
to women women had to fight for their
right no women never had to fight
what do you mean women didn't have to
fight for these rights they literally
had marching women were hard for this
lake for the First Amendment and second
amendment women the right to vote for
the right to not be treated as property
okay so that's interesting you bring up
the right to vote so you say we fought
for it everyone except for white men
know some women did but fill minority it
was mostly white men women at first who
didn't include black women okay so who
do you believe procured the right for
women to vote women fighting for it
really yeah why men one not gave it to
him and if they didn't fight for it so
you believe a majority of women fought
for suffragettes fought for the right to
vote I don't know if it was a majority
but I know women did and we wouldn't
have it those women hadn't stood up for
it okay
well because I seem to move on to a
historical timeline historically that's
actually not accurate the majority of
women so women actually the majority
woman didn't want the right to vote I
told you it I didn't know if it was the
majority but it wouldn't have happened
if wouldn't haven't stood up and this
stuff for just well the reason I bring
that up is because you said it women and
minorities fought for that right not
white men when the fact is women
actually as a majority didn't fight for
that right many of them fought against
it
white men fought for that and were the
ones who signed that into law
because of women and they wouldn't have
sign it into law a woman hadn't made
them sign it into law but they didn't
the majority of women didn't want it
that's my point the reason I didn't want
it by the way we'll move on from this
was because of the fact that voting came
with the draft mandatory bucket duty
responsibilities that were actually not
bestowed upon women at that time and
they didn't want the right to vote
because it would come with the same
responsibilities and so women got the
right to vote but they didn't have to be
a part of the draft or mandatory bucket
to the mandatory firefighting service so
historically I'm just saying that's
actually it's not really accurate it
paints in an accurate picture I know
children there was an anti suffragist
movement
I know conservative women didn't want
the right to vote but it's because of
women that they were given the right to
vote and there's of course there's gonna
be people on each side but there's gonna
be women who want to stay in the home
but the whole point of women fighting
for it is so they have that choice to
stay in the home or go out to vote short
or go into the draft if they want to I
don't think you respectfully
fundamentally have a misunderstanding of
the draft no I go in I didn't believe in
drafting any one at all I don't play at
a time it was a part of voting that's my
point my only point here is you said it
was a society designed by white men
exclusively for white men and gave some
examples which weren't accurate so let
me bring us to today what rights are
afforded in 2018 to men exclusively that
aren't afforded to women and I would I
would like both either to answer Lena I
don't want you to sit there and feel
like I'm I don't want to cut you out of
it I think really well I just don't
think you're understanding her side and
how she's saying that it was a two-sided
thing so there are women who want to
stay at home and live that life and
there are women who wanted the right to
vote to have their voice heard in their
representation sure and I think you want
to you want to focus on the
Conservatives I don't want to say at
home and she's trying to say no no no
well they got the option to stay at home
because other women were fighting for
their right to vote no that's not what I
was that's not what I was presenting
from my site at all
no let me let me clarify one more time
than okay and I want I want to get
really clear not only for you for anyone
watching you said this was a society
created by white men exclusively for
white men and women and minorities had
to fight for these rights and use
examples as voting and white men didn't
what I am pointing out is that as
inaccurate white men did
most women didn't want it so that's a
false premise that pates a false it
paints a [ __ ] it's a false baseline for
today because if you say at one point
I'm not not it I think women should have
the right to vote I'm very glad that we
all do okay we can agree on that what I
can't agree with is something that is
historically inaccurate so I'd like to
find something we agree on
today what rights today in 2018 are
afforded to men that are not afforded to
women I don't believe that there's
systemic male privilege today I'm not
saying I'm entire I could be wrong I
don't believe it though and I would like
to be convinced or I'm certainly open to
being convinced I feel you're a male
privilege privilege is a myth I feel
like only white men have that male
privilege and that's what the focus
should be on okay so there's no black
male privilege no okay
we have some black men and actually in
the audience maybe they can come in
afterwards I would be interested to hear
their perspective so white male
privilege yes okay so what systemic
white male privilege exists a what
rights are afforded for example to white
males that are not afforded to black
males or to white males not afforded to
black females let's divide everyone by
race and gender at this point in regards
to like laws and things like that
obviously the laws aren't like Oh white
men get this prevalent ball of law so in
regard in regards to like technical
terms it says like men it's laid out by
laws really equally when it comes to the
actual systems there's tons of black men
crowding jails for an eighth of weed
well you know white men have like weed
parties and it's cool and that's their
thing but like black men are
automatically arrested for it
so that goes into the whole like police
brutality argument but so can I ask can
I ask you that I've never heard of a
weed party you mean one of the white
males probably yeah
yeah no I don't okay it will have
someone come in afterwards like explain
to me a weed party so I'm no genuine
this is this is not me being explained
I'm sure they do but the premise was the
idea right that black men are in prison
for an eighth of weed do you have any
statistical data to prove that black men
with nothing more than a degree go to
prison I couldn't give you the exact
statistics but there are several
accounts of it and it's not unknown it's
pretty much common sense that blacks are
weight easily more arrested than white
men well it apparently it's also been
common sense that the majority of women
were pushing for the right to vote and
that white men didn't support them so
we're trying to deconstruct some of
these ideas that people may be assumed
are common sense but are factually
inaccurate now the truth is men as a
whole are much more likely to be
incarcerated than women men as a whole
even white men get far more harsh
sentencing for the same crime as women
are shooting up schools so I think they
should have a harsher punished
well hold on a second I mean black black
hold on but hold on a thing but black
men are shooting each other in record
numbers that's not really relevant to
the point hold on one second hold on one
second from the n-double a-c-p you said
for an eighth I want to make sure we're
really clear here you said white men are
having weed parties and a black man with
an eighth of weed will be incarcerated
in a federal prison so what I have here
is your source from the n-double-a-cp
from the n-double-a-cp
in 2014 African Americans constituted
2.3 million or 34% 64% of the curricular
correctional population ok African
Americans are incarcerated at more than
five times the rate of whites now
nothing here at all involves behaviors
or crimes committed I'm trying to look
for anything in here that relates to
black people being sentenced simply for
an eighth of weed
so this is from the n-double-a-cp that
would be his bias of a source as you
could use but I don't see it I don't see
it show me give me I would like to see I
would be very open to hearing the
statistical reality I'm not trying to be
I would I'm not trying to be
confidential I would like to hear that
stat I think it's horrible I don't think
anyone should be arrested for an eighth
of weed or put in jail I think we can
agree on that right whether they're
white or black I think I don't think
white people should be shutting up
schools whether the white or black okay
so let's assume that that will and so I
hope I hope you're still comfortable I
don't want to make anyone I I feel this
has been respectful and you've been very
polite so again the systemic differences
we're talking about you know men period
are more likely to be incarcerated women
men are more likely to be physically
assaulted than women
so we're getting into this first off
this is data but when we get into the
anecdotal that well white men tend to
have it better because they can walk
around and have weed parties it's not
necessarily accurate so particularly
when we're discussing an issue as
sensitive as race gender and systemic
oppression or inequalities don't you
think it's really important that we get
that correct and the premise correct
before we go off and divide people by
these subcategories yeah but I think
there's tons of statistics out there
already and even if you don't want to
look up the statistics it's not hard to
see how many black men are in jail at
larger it's then why then two black men
commit crimes at a higher rate than men
know so you know black men do not commit
crimes at a higher rate than white males
do you have statistics that would
reflect that but it's definitely not
true it's because
since racism is built into the system
that's what the system of its built
against blacks and that's what racism is
that's why there are more blacks in
prisons okay what stealers have gotten
away from male priviledge now we've
gotten to black white but I'll go with
that if you'd like to and I don't
disagree that there have been horrible
instances of racism in this country
including by the way in Canada and of
course in Europe the British Empire and
by the way I hope you understand I'm
certainly not a slavery or racism
apologist I think that's bad I think
racism is bad but you just mentioned
that someone else was just earlier was
saying that he I was okay with rape
which I'm not simply because I believe
there needs to be proof for rape so I
think racism is bad if we can all agree
that racism is bad you say the systems
are racist and setup okay what's
systemic racism do we have today then in
that case therefore careful colored
people it's people of color one's racist
ones okay now
I've never been given the Equality
please never again been given the equal
of competing for jobs because they after
racism was abolished okay segregation
and Jim Crow and separate but equal so
people of color never been given the
same opportunity is white people which
is why it's been built into the system
in 2018 do you believe that's true
okay can I ask you a question your ID
here at to go to TCU at ECU do you know
if there is any affirmative action for
example grants exclusively given to
people of African American heritage so
there are grants and scholarships I
think we would agree across this country
for minorities we not say that's so
these I just want to make sure that I
understand these scholarships correctly
because I don't attend the school so
these are you said it's the community
grant for my it's is that what it's
called community scholar community
scholar and this is exclusively for
minorities to try and get them on campus
minorities but you can be any race you
get this scholarship okay so this is
something spittle
I'm a lower economic standpoint okay are
there or are there not grants for
example or laws in place we know
affirmative action that would be granted
exclusively toward minorities apparent
it seems in this case this one may not
but are you aware that those exist on
campus yes
so when you say minority that would be
excluding people who are not minorities
for this grant or scholarship correct is
that discriminatory no because it's it's
fighting against the system of race
actually about the system of racism
asking is by definition is that
discriminating against groups of people
for this grant what is the definition of
the word discrimination I would venture
would be something along the lines of
discerning or excluding certain
parameters or qualities from a given
opportunity treatment of different
categories of people or things
especially on the grounds of race age or
sex
okay so excluding people based on race
merriam-webster okay here that's
appreciated so the idea is the point is
there's discrimination occurring there
is there anything like that for white
students it's making it equal to get to
TCU I don't know what you're it's you're
a figment of our imagination oh hold on
a second
sorry you're Asian so I guess you don't
count because there are too many of you
on campus I'm saying I'm looking at many
there's a guy biracial right here no
Alyssa there been people coming in and
out the point is many of these people
disagree they believe they can get in to
school they don't believe they're
systemic discrimination there are more
white people in this area of town and
we've gotten away from male privilege we
talk about white privilege versus black
privileges now we're talking are people
of people of color it's people of colors
at the term you prefer I don't know I
know some people fur black something for
people of color I would like to go back
to the idea of male privilege I still
haven't heard a right afforded or
sitting with race I still haven't ready
right afforded to someone who was a
white male not afforded to say a black
female
I think and I think that's pivotal if
we're gonna talk about systemic
discrimination sorry my knee touched you
I apologize I meant nothing by it I just
have wide legs but we undergo that's
pivotal for going to say there is
systemic discrimination that needs to be
just that needs to be rectified we would
need to be able to find in 2018 at least
one example of systemic discrimination
ok presidents have been in males the
last one was black one and I would argue
he was terrible that's fine and isn't it
wonderful you can have that opinion
right you can have that opinion and I
can in my opinion but wouldn't that be
proof that there are no more barriers to
entry if a black man made it to the
highest office in the land no what do
you do I mean she's trying to get her
point across he just needs the letter
say it there's there's lots of countries
where they elected one minority
president and they went all the way back
to electing all white presidents they
say they're careful because you're
treading on some ground that could make
you sound very racist here and I don't
think you're aware of it some of what's
been said here you're a white opinion of
racism doesn't
that's kind of no I didn't know listen I
would never use the word reverse racism
saying your white opinion racing doesn't
matter is not reverse racism at all it
already doesn't matter it's just it
doesn't compare okay how so like you're
trying to tell her what she's saying is
racist I don't know I said it could come
across racist saying they never vote in
another black president again how people
don't ever vote that you know that could
that could come across as racist because
of such a poor performance from a black
president would be the application
exactly it is my opinion and was the
opinion of many many millions of
Americans who voted in an old white guy
unfortunately over a woman sorry maybe
we'll have a female president next
governor I gladly vote for a female
president I actually was a Carly Fiorina
guy I really liked her I think she would
make a fantastic brother but I do find
an inching right here where you just
said that your white opinion isn't
comparable III don't the word comparable
is interesting to me why would you use
that choice of words because what what
is your understanding of racism in
comparison to somebody who's a person of
color this we're both human beings with
opinions on an issue yeah but you play
into the system and we're trying to
fight against it so why would how would
you know that I play into this how do I
play into the system you're a
conservative Republican like you don't
know anything about me
you're sitting here saying that male
privilege is a myth and that rape
culture isn't a problem on US campuses
and so you just said I am a part of a
system which you just declared racist
you said I'm an active part in a racist
system that's that's a really terrible
thing to say about somebody well is it
untrue yes then prove it what you want
to prove okay you wanted to disprove
your prejudicial statement based on my
race let me give you my best shot I'm
actually a french-canadian or an English
Canadian who is raised in French Canada
are you aware of the language police
yeah
okay so slowly talking about a little
bit about discrimination we're actually
not allowed to attend Dingell
schools when I allowed to open a
restaurant with an English sign if
there's an apostrophe s they thought I
was learning able to disabled until the
fourth grade because I was forced to go
to French schools and learn math
geography and history in French by law
because if you are born in Quebec you
have to attend French schools this comes
from a theory they call PL n which means
pure wool pure European French blood
wool and so this is actually something
that's enforced by the language police
where I grew up they thought I was
learning disabled as an English Canadian
being forced to go to public Catholic
schools at a Protestant english-speaking
Canadian and they thought I was learning
disabled until the 4th grade I lived in
82 dotson for several months as I try to
make something myself and dropped out of
college and moved to the United States
when I was 18 years so I certainly
wouldn't say that I'm someone who's been
raised in the lap of white American
Republican privilege by the way there
are no Republicans in Quebec there are
only liberals and liberal separatists
none of what you said had to do with
race got to do with discrimination with
prejudice I would say there's an English
peak but you're still a white man in the
society so you're you're good--you're I
would just I would say I would say this
and I think you're not going to like
this but I would say a white male
regardless of white male black I would
say white speaking English Canadian
living being raised in French Canada yes
would face much more systemic oppression
than you hear in college campus really
so it's easier being you a white person
in America than me a white person I mean
I'm a white person in America you're
halfway prisoner may know something my
upbringing because you said you're
playing into the system you're a white
male conservative Republican yeah white
male Democrat
fighting the system what's it trying to
change the systemic rate maybe one
example of such brutality okay police
brutality ignore them we're just having
a conversation and the peanut gallery
doesn't matter okay that's okay I'm not
I'm not laughing at you I'm not I'm not
being disrespected I don't associate
with them not I'm not just saying I'm
saying I've want to just keep it here so
that it's not fair if there's a pile
and I want everyone to take their turn
so I appreciate it
police brutality that's interesting
again with the sign is about male
privilege but you seem to really focus
on the race issues let's talk about
police brutality how is that so the
example of sis the system that you say I
play into and they here proactively in
America police brutality is an example
of systemic discrimination white male
privilege yes because black men are
killed at traffic stops black women
included I mean they're unjust killings
in jail that mysteriously I mean these
men kill young black men and then walk
free like your life and your privilege
is fine but black people are dying so
you you believe that it's okay it's
legal to kill a an innocent black male
and it's happening in record numbers yes
were white not because you're white but
because the system is racist what if I
were to tell you that statistically
that's untrue
I would want to know this is history
yeah whatever hotel actually white males
are more likely to be shot by police
okay why wasn't the Florida shooter shot
dead then well we're getting any
anecdotal
okay so statistically empirical data
would say that actually white males are
more likely to be shot by the police
okay but I just completely disagree with
that and I don't know where your
statistic is coming from okay well I
let's I think when some other people who
would like to discuss but if you
disagree with the statistics I we have
them up on the website I think it's
horrible if anyone is shot an innocent
person stopped by the police let me use
better training with a lot of police
officers de-escalation I think that
should be used with white or black
people but I think one thing um if I may
because I'm sorry did I step on your
foot no walnut here one thing if I might
if the goal is to have a conversation I
really do want to have a conversation
I've tried to be respectful just as I'm
sure you would probably be more
defensive or less less capable of having
a civil dialogue with someone if they
said well you're you can't possibly
understand because you're a black woman
you don't know anything about this I'm
sure right away you might say what
mean by that coming into a conversation
with someone where you don't have
empirical data or evidence I presented
some you've disagreed with some you
haven't presented much of your own but
saying that someone's opinion simply
isn't comparable because they're a white
male a is not a valid argument I hope
that's not one that's taught as okay in
college and it's also not something
that's going to convert anyone to your
way of thinking the idea is to change my
mind I will tell you I appreciate you
sitting down and doing it but that is
probably the least effective way to
enter a conversation if you're looking
to change someone's mind to say you're
wrong or you don't know because you're a
white male so I would hope that moving
forward that maybe you might reconsider
your your tax because you seem like like
you seem very much like a nice lady I
don't think you're aware of that but um
it shuts down dialogue before it begins
as opposed to encouraging what it is
like to be oppressed because you are
like my males are not oppressed yeah
first off I'd like her to explain her
position Marilyn said seems a little
seems a little like what do we call it
white splaining I told that I said I
think this is what she was trying to say
that's why I didn't say I think this is
what she said but do you not believe
that she can articulate I don't I don't
want her to feel as though she's being
misrepresented I feel totally fine
let me ask you this because we've talked
about data we've talked about the facts
but she said you don't have in front of
you but let's not take my word for it so
you just said white men can't know what
it's like to be oppressed do you believe
that as an emphatic factual statement
that there are no white men in this
country who could know what it's like to
be oppressed or maybe haven't had some
hard breaks they've had hard times but
they're definitely not oppressed okay
that's fair I appreciate I would did I
would just I would disagree I think
everyone has privilege in different
facets and I think on campus I think
women and people of minority people have
a privilege that the average white male
here probably doesn't scale or ships
grants the ability to shout people down
tell them they'd go out there now the
right to an opinion because they're a
white male I would never even dream of
telling either of you that your opinion
is invalid because you're a woman you're
black no that's not allowed you're not
allowed to tell me to stop talking sorry
if I were to do that you'd say that
that's white male privilege so I
appreciate it the conversation is kind
of over it's not going anywhere
thank you it's over thank you well then
then just great I think everyone on here
is on board with scholarships for the
smartest people in any class male male
female black or white I don't think race
or sex should even come into the
equation so could we agree with on
coming on thank you very much now like
you said she she just sort of I guess
claimed the mantle of all black people
though she was black splinting yes she
was black splaining which I wouldn't
know if she worked because I ike if
you're black splaining that's it's
probably out of necessity sometimes I
sometimes I find myself going down a
rabbit hole of the internet you know I
know that there are some white Americans
completely out of touch with black
culture sometimes I go over the world
star hiphop it's like a whole new world
I'm not gonna lie like this whole
thing's you're like this has been going
on this entire time you know what I'm
not watching this is still a thing
alright but this was really cool a black
guy and an asian guy who were there and
one thing I will say to to change my
mind segments um we've talked about how
the left is willing to just boom shout
out and yell a lot in there that will go
three hours sometimes like 45 minutes
two hours three hours is exaggerated
call it four to five minutes two hours
no one and then one person sits down and
then liberal professors and students
you've seen it they start yelling yeah
uh in this instance there were a couple
of times where I was talking with them
those two girls there and I don't know I
said something I made some point and
someone chimed in who was on the right
that you know more conservative leaning
and say hey guys listen I don't want to
do I don't want to do a pylon let's let
them finish their thought and you could
I don't know if I have a shot of the
audience you could see the audience the
Conservatives going and everyone got
quiet yeah they didn't go oh damn and
jump in they all went yeah you know what
that's right the whole purpose of this
is two people having a conversation and
that to me again it was just something I
thought well this is this is really cool
people actually acknowledging yeah we
don't want to be cowards I think that's
that is something that's kind of been a
an illuminating thing for me is seeing
in action in play this idea that the mob
mentality of the left where they kind of
have to concrete together directly and
overpower somebody else's voice to kind
of shout someone else down
whereas conservatives I think are tend
to be more apt to just saying hey let's
let it breathe let's see what happens
here
yeah back off let's that these two
people discuss our ideas because we
believe in the ideas we don't think we
have to shout someone down rightly
concede we just think let's see the
ideas play out yeah and you see that a
lot we were obviously the the teachers
called the patriarchy they called the
police on me even though we had permits
so this has happened we've had permits
you know at SMU and that at t Z and we
were in a believe in Vermont
and it doesn't matter sometimes so
that's why we have the permit running
out the big theatre in March 22nd to do
SMU and it can try and run us out in the
rails we welcome it but so that was
pretty cool and then this organic
conversations was sort of its spawned
from basically a black guy saying I I
don't agree and okay you want to come
out you wanna you want to talk about it
and an Asian guys saying like actually
my family they're first-generation
immigrants and I don't I don't agree
with a lot of the stuff she said
something do you want to come out and
then we were bridging the racial divide
like heroin it brings people of all
different colors and creeds together in
its warm embrace so enjoy this in I
guess unpredictable it was not something
that we had an impromptu non front ation
changed my mind or the black and an
oriental you know what could you sit
down for a second
took a black eye Sean I Sean um so Sean
I find this do you do you agree with
what was just stated there as a black
male no okay I didn't have to think
about it with what part do you disagree
well first off the statistics about like
black crime and police brutality overly
affecting black males I mean we have to
look at crime statistics so yes black
males are over represented in prisons
but black males are also over
represented in crisis so black males are
like what like was it like six percent
uh six six or seven percent of the
population right six from the population
because why females are seven yeah yeah
I think I think its total at some around
thirteen yeah total total is 13 yeah
yeah so I mean if you take all that to
account then you have to consider okay
so why why are they over-represented and
crime and the reason why I mean in my
opinion it's a lot of it is economic a
lot of it is cultural a lot of it is you
know the the opportunities available in
their areas and people can make the
argument that it's oh it's because of
white oppression I don't necessarily
things because of my depression I think
asked a lot to do with the welfare state
I think it has a lot to do with
Democratic policies and liberal policies
pushing agendas upon black people
instead of giving them agency in the
line to make their own decisions she
left I was hoping that you could
actually she would actually hear what
you have to say here let me ask people
do you attend TCU I do how did you get
in spent nine years in the Air Force and
got a scholarship for scholarship thank
you for your efforts appreciate and what
are you studying psychology and
philosophy so excellent okay so in the
liberal arts I'd yeah well listen if you
make less than a civil engineer don't
blame it on a white black thing you
chose a degree that's kind of right
there you go
well listen that sounds like something
that would be especially after eight
years in the Air Force I use nine years
geez sorry look something like nine get
it right do you do so you were in the
Air Force this is what got your
scholarship do you believe that your
path was more difficult to TCU
exclusively because of your race no I
don't think is because of my race I
think it's because you know I was raised
by a single mother my dad left when I
was
young sorry you know my mom had to work
really hard to you know just get me
through school I made really poor
decisions early on in life and the
military is really the only way I could
go and honestly I learned a lot in the
military I got a lot of uh learned
responsibility responsibility for my own
actions and I learned agency and taking
pride in myself yeah how do you feel
about I see I'm not exactly I don't I'm
not totally aware of the scholarship
specifically to TCU but I think everyone
is well aware of when we can agree there
are scholarships obviously afforded
exclusively to minorities or women not
afford it to say the white male how do
you feel about that as a black know do
you think that that helps no actually we
were just talking about this actually
else when the Asian you can't talk with
him there over things they'd be
dominating every math and science
department there is got to build a wall
around their neighborhood just so we can
keep some people getting degrees trying
out loud yeah stay from the Bay Area and
Silicon Valley and I mean you see
they're like Asian prosperity is huge oh
yeah they're doing really well and like
good on them and I think like honestly
if the black culture adopted a lot of
those tenets of like Asian culture and
like hey suck it up like go out there
and get it and do it yourself in it like
it's interesting like a lot of rappers
supported Trump and they said the reason
why is because I said you know that's
what Trump is about he's like go out
there and get it make your money do what
you have to do to make your money right
and I think like that's you know people
talk about that but they don't really go
out and do it like there's not a lot of
talk about different ways and and
diversifying your means of income yeah
there are a lot of opportunities out
there if you just go out there and look
for me and get it and honestly like
people are willing to give life of
opportunities here's the OL I understand
that there are racists out there and I
think it's kind of like you know a child
who just misbehaves so often you have to
discipline them you kind of see this
with the left like if a child behaves
well okay you don't have to correct them
all the time but when the when the left
constantly just divides by race and by
gender then you have to bounce back and
say well hold on a second no that's
actually inaccurate the truth is it kind
of bars us that it robs us of our
ability to be empathetic to someone
saying yeah you know what I'm sure you
get some tough breaks to the black guy
because we're constantly being told you
can't understand and you've got
everything because you're a white guy I
think it actually burns more bridges
than it builds I agree I agree
wholeheartedly yeah I mean what do you
think what do you think agents think
when they're saying you're too much
they're actually only a yeah well you
know what actually here if you want to
come action you can stay here well let's
get let's get like buddy cot like a
buddy cop film damnit sir my hands are
freezing a list aren't blue you know
it's funny that you mention that about
your AC T scores and how your friend who
was african-american got in and you
didn't this is one thing that I've
always I'm glad we finally look we can
bridge this racial divide it's like the
black and white cookie Seinfeld when you
think about that right there actually
they start blocking Asians out because
you guys do very very well academically
what do you think that does to the
relationship between Asian Americans and
black Americans that's always a concern
of mine I mean same thing with white
Americans but particularly a snide grew
up in Canada
and um I'm not gonna lie a lot of Asians
behind closed doors a little bit racist
in Canada I'm sure there's some of that
here too it seems like it would strain
relationships not really bring people
together yeah I like the Asian culture
is very strong academics first academic
second or diverge it's like with the
whole shaming your family kind of like
concept you see with like white culture
right white media like they talk about
all you by you not doctor yet which is
actually there could be very true so
like is like and I know they have
America especially the inner cities like
academic academic excellence and
teammates very shunned upon especially
would like the games and stuff like that
yeah I got that pretty big divide
especially on like the income
ethnic like traveling the table what for
for ethnic groups in America top earners
are all Asians Indians like Japanese hi
yeah they love the bottom tears or
whatever instead Hispanics and I think
it just because of it's not because of
the systemic racism in America all
Fulcher like that sorry about that like
yeah white Africans single motherhood
rate during a sub regime it was what
like lurch in 50 percent depending on
the city words now it's upwards of
seventy eighty percent the inner cities
and that's not because of racism from
white people that's because of the shins
and culture and the inner cities who
actually do do you agree with what he's
saying there yeah I do
yeah I think a lot of it has to do with
the soft bigotry of low expectations
when you tell people that you know oh
well you can't do anything in life
because you have this overlord above you
yeah oppressing you then like what what
is your you know you're not gonna have
any optimism you're not gonna have any
aspirations to achieve anything in life
right because you're like what's the
point and I think that's told more to
black males and as black females because
there is statistical just came out that
black females are actually the most
educated minority group per capita
United States I did reason yeah which is
like insane you know you think about
like well what how are they oppressive
they're you know having you know
unfortunately that's the testicle begin
to it includes one of the gender studies
and that kind of stuff Wow let me ask
you this because you mentioned sort of
cultural differences if I'm asked a
personal question you don't have to
answer it but I appreciate your candor
you talked about sort of the the culture
of academics there's also you know
there's an argument to be made that
obviously um specifically like Chinese
the language is more mathematical so you
have more an advantage there right and
that's that's actually I've even heard
have you ever read the tipping point
where it talks about actually the
difference in crops between like corn
and rice and how sensitive rice is and
how meticulous you have to be when
you're cultivating rice versus corn
which is kind of a yield anything crop
so there are cultural differences there
that would place emphasis on mathematics
on Sciences but there is a very notable
cultural difference as you talked about
with families where fathers tend to stay
in the household with Asian family so
let me ask is given all the other
cultural differences this is why I asked
I know you brought it up yourself that
youyou were single-mother household do
you think that having a family structure
like yet having your father be there
would have been probably the biggest
determining factor in giving you a leg
up
to everything else we've discussed yes
yeah just having that kind of like that
like Stern kind of figure in your life
that you know that stability there right
I definitely think I would have help
because you know I didn't and and people
talk about like there's no there's no
biological factor to gender and that's
that's absurd because having a man in
the house has a completely different
impression illusion then otherwise
because when my uncle's would come over
I would I would you know kind of tighten
up right away light up don't know act
out yeah and I think you know most
people that have fathers in the
household like that's their you know
that's kind of the rock I mean most
people most men or boys when they get
into puberty like they're not really
afraid of them anymore
I definitely wasn't yeah I was give me a
SWAT if I need one you know essentially
earlier you said something to you're
both sitting there and that you're kind
of laughing you said something something
effective maybe you can correct me if
I'm wrong since I'm like I'm black until
but people don't think I am once I once
I speak yeah what do you what do you
it's inching that you said that and you
were so what do you mean by that so I
grew up in California so you know
speaking without Ebonics without slang
isn't abnormal there but as soon as I
stay in Louisiana for six years and when
I got to Louisiana
I would walk into any you know
McDonald's or whatever and immediate
they'd like you're not from around here
are you yeah and no I'm not no okay well
it's also a Louisiana like you're from a
socialist state yeah that's probably
what they smelled it on you know listen
it's not like all black guys in
California I mean I lived in Inglewood
for a while yeah I mean I you know you
know it's not straight out of Compton I
know what I know yes okay okay yeah sure
so what's just interesting you say that
do you feel as though like you've talked
about this right with Asians how there's
a certain you feel their expectations
and pressures yeah
which in your family to be your our
history like if I you look back and let
these your culture throughout
early ages do in China interested
spirited family structures so sound and
like the whole fact that you have to
prove I definitely show your work your
family yeah or your disown it earn it I
mean if it's a reason why it South Korea
Japan of to high suicide rates in the
made and the entire world I knew it was
Japan I don't know sound sorry looks
higher so really we implement the
hardest high school like curriculums and
there's a placement test that basically
tells you where you go in life and so
it's about the suicide rate after that
tests become scores come out is so
astronomically high compared to like oh
I can imagine
so well first off I don't think that's
necessarily healthy
okay I'm not says but but am saying but
it is clearly obviously in the indicator
of academic pursuits and performance I
just find anything because he mention
the pressures on them and then you
mentioned you know I don't sound black
so you feel whether you realize it to
some varying degree freshers to sound a
certain way so it's similar to the Asian
pressures but what are the pressures
there how are you expected to sound and
where we do those external pressures
come from you know it's honestly I got
it from growing up especially and like I
said I didn't do that well in life right
cool and a lot of those because of the
pressures and there's like you'd better
not be a nerd if you're in nerd you can
beat up right let's just that's just the
way it is right so you can't like things
that aren't you know stereotypical for
the culture so if you like country music
and I don't necessarily like punch music
but okay I war to like country music you
can walk home safely tonight on campus
Dec guy said he liked us a crown ban him
so yeah like you know things like that
are like after-school activities things
like that if you're stick around after
school you're not cool anymore
right and and it's it's more cool to
like cut class and you know
you know I mean that's well let me ask
you this would you say that these
pressures you talked about within your
families in your society would you say
that that shaped your behavior as a
young person more than say I don't know
Bernie Sanders his recent vote in the
Senate floor yeah I mean for most people
like you if your parents are successful
or they that's something you want and
imitate and we don't have a family
structure that like supports you and
like shows you what's right or wrong
you're gonna grow up doing what you
think is right or right and without that
development you're right or wrong it's
going to be all about you right and
you'd be so egotistical self-centered
like you're gonna be the only thing
about yourself that's what crime happens
that's when you like murderers that's
when you know people that like they feel
like oh they're oppressed because no
it's just everything's against them it
is that's one thing we've noticed is
being with the more leftist students who
I appreciate that they came forward but
is is this sort of what is raising okay
you can take it you can take a picture
of me I don't care I don't that sure I
don't have to charge him for it you know
these pressures and and and people seem
to confuse that because that's sort of
anecdotal but it's it's anecdotal in the
sense that it's anecdotal within like
you're saying the frizam of your race
there are certain pressures that come
with being a black person a certain
culture an Asian person and they seem to
conflate that with systemic
discrimination one constant we've
noticed day is not a single person could
list us an actual write an actual
systemic form of oppression and so they
go to the anecdotal and it's funny
that's one thing I would real it readily
acknowledged if you were to say for
example hey you know what
one thing you don't really know is a
white guy I'll tell you is being raised
as a black kid in an area of California
and a single-mother household you know
it was hard for me if I wanted to study
or did he's like because I would have
been made fun of that's just not safe
you were to say hey man one thing you
don't really understand as a white guy
is um you know my mom locked me in a
closet and beat the [ __ ] out of me with
reeds if I didn't you know do my math
homework I would say oh wow that's
interesting let's have a discussion but
instead it's just you can't possibly
understand because of a system and
you're playing into a systemic
form of oppression I will tell you this
really we don't have those kinds of
pressures as white people I think we'd
all readily acknowledge that we
have certain expectations of us as white
people except ironically enough the one
sort of consistent pressurized ecosystem
right now for white people is a pressure
to feel guilty and that's what we've had
today everyone who's come up has tried
to tell me to feel guilty for being a
white male to feel guilty for a rape
that may or may not have occurred with
no proof to feel guilty because someone
was sitting here was a black female
that's the pressure we get and that's
not healthy because it just it just
creates resentment so I'd say if you do
want a debate about anything I will say
if there is a white privilege that is
the white privilege that you aren't
dictated to based on your race now with
the Enlightenment you got individuality
you can be yourself you can be whoever
you want to be and people can judge you
for it but you know like that's it's no
it's no big deal like it's okay to be
whoever you want to be right and I don't
think that's the case for a lot of
minority groups I think I think that's
true and I think that would be
interesting conversation to have
and I think we just kind of had it but
like the only system pressure now is
guilt we're expected to feel guilty
let's say you do really well for
yourself none of your black friends
you're like man you got that from a
system of oppression you've just played
into the system in your life if anything
they'll say now you owe the community
which is you know why you see a lot of
rappers like I'm gonna move away where
the ice cube or ice-t who moved back and
then he was like he moved away three
months later he's like you know I went
back in tried to help my community but
turns out my community really likes to
steal my and he left yeah so I will
listen this was this is totally off
topic for all we were doing but I just I
heard them speaking on your behalf as
minorities and man I appreciate you guys
sitting that in talking this is this is
awesome thank you man
and thank you very service thank you hey
did you enjoy this video here's your
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it
and you want to justify it leave a
comment below telling us why you didn't
like the video and if you liked us let
us know and subscribe to the channel
because that lets the overlords at
YouTube know that you know what you're
alright